[Musique]
oh pas de sens aujourd'hui
1 2 3 4
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
salut tout le monde cette semaine joueur
du grenier met les pieds sur la table je
ne fous rien
non sérieusement le test sur tortues
ninja m'a légèrement troublée enfin bref
donc cette semaine senna vidéo touchette
et pour ce coup-ci j'ai décidé de me
pencher sur une console préhistorique à
laquelle je veux dire que je joue pas
souvent jusque c'est pas vraiment une
console de ma génération je la plupart
des jeux dont je vous parlais sont
sortis quand j'avais à peine un ou deux
ans je parle de l'atari 2600 sortie en
81 en france la plus célèbre des
consoles atari puisqu'il ya eu plusieurs
consoles fait par cette marque mais en
général quand tu n'y a jamais tel jeu
sur atari on parle par défaut souvent de
l'atari 2600 alors évidemment les jeux
sur cette console était terriblement
simpliste et puis c'est très difficile
de juger ce avec le recul après tout
c'était quand même la première console
grand public alors est ce que je te
réellement parler de ses joueurs aller
dessus sans être d'une mauvaise foi
complète
bien sûr que non mais ça ne m'empêchera
pas de le faire tiens je vais prendre un
jeu typique de l'atari ati moule agence
tous risques c'est le foutoir
incompréhensible il ya une tête de
barracuda qui se promènent sur l'écran
en tirant sur des mecs qui portent des
poutres dégâts en chapeau melon des
caisses que c'est un chanteur des pet
shop boys
est ce que quelqu'un voit le rapport
avec l' agence tous risques
ici c'est bien sans problème des jeux
atari la limitation de la console oblige
le joueur à se servir de son imagination
non la seule chose que j'imagine quand
je vois ça c'est que les mecs qui ont
créé ça avait des sérieux problèmes
un peu comme ceux qui ont fait ce jeu ce
n'est qu'un pic au cache-cache si vous
préférez alors moi déjà personnellement
j'ai beaucoup de mal à comprendre
l'intérêt de jeux vidéo de cache-cache
alors que bon c'est le jeu qui se joue
facilement dans une maison par
définition ici le principe est simple on
joue chacun son tour en allant se cacher
dans la maison pour que l'autre ne nous
trouvent pas mais là par contre j'ai une
question très conne est-ce que j'ai
l'esprit tordu est ce que c'est un bras
extrêmement mal placées par les
développeurs du jeu
ou est-ce que ces deux personnages
jouent à cache cache avec leur poireau a
l'air enfin je veux dire me dites pas
que vous aimez pas français
[Musique]
oh mon dieu je veux pas savoir ce qui se
passe là derrière
en plus c'est terriblement d'asile n'y a
que quelques endroits où on peut se
cacher derrière le fauteuil sous les
fondations de la maison dans le lit
allez tiens deviné je suis caché à ce
jeu est très court 1 x vous est en fait
tous les jeux de l'atari durée rarement
plus d'une heure mais c'est plus court
de l'atari est le plus court de l'atari
c'est celui là attention top chrono
[Musique]
voilà bah je sais pas combien coûte et
les jeux atari à cette époque mais ça
fait mal aux fesses quand même mais il y
avait pire encore prenez ce jeu par
exemple charlotte aux fraises
imaginez vous achetez le jeu en magasin
vous rentrez chez vous vous mettez ça
dans la console et vous voyez ça
[Musique]
ce truc a vraiment été vendu dans un
magasin contre de l'argent
voilà là vous venez de voir
l'intégralité du jeu de charlotte aux
fraises en même temps aujourd'hui d'en
douter quand j'ai vu la jaquette aussi
suivant masters of the universe musclor
pour les français alors le trop de ce
jeu pour l'époque et carrément
fantastique et il ya la musique du
dessin animé la transformation de
musclor et après ça on a droit à quoi
[Musique]
un pauvre jeu de shoot injouable en plus
et monstrueusement difficile il faut
détruire ses bâtons lancées par les
ennemis jurés de musclor que sont les
rumeurs et c'est presque un faisable ces
machins là suivent le scrolling de
l'écran et en plus pour soutirer des
trucs là bas la poursuite situer les
bidules et j'ai aucune idée de comment
faire de temps en temps
complètement par hasard j'arrive à tirer
le rayon amber desai jamais au bon
endroit merde
et puis plein d'eau si je veux dire
merde puis quand tu achètes jeu sur
musclor tu t'attends à quoi tu t'attends
à taper sur ce que les teurs avec une
grosse épée dans une ambiance
partiellement beau sexuelle mais tu
t'attends pas un jeu de vaisseau non
sérieusement faudra vraiment que je
regarde les boîtes à l'avenir shayna
syndrome un jeu de shoot comme il en
existe plein sur la console
alors quel rapport entre la chine et un
jeu de shoot vous me direz et bien
d'après la boîte l'histoire c'est un
tremblement de terre qui aurait
endommagé réacteurs nucléaires quelque
part en asie provoquant une surchauffe
du réacteur et contaminant la région
alentour
c'est totalement irréaliste
voilà mais si en fait je vous montre ce
jeu c'est surtout pour vous faire
écouter le son magnifique du game over
bon pour les oreilles
ça c'est le genre de jeu où quand il
ajouté par an il déboule dans la salle à
manger il débranche l'abri d'un croyant
de la télé va exploser non sérieusement
vous connaissez un son ou une musique et
pire que tout ça va ça ça compte pas là
les jeux de shoot injouable sur atari
n'avait vraiment une blinde comme
megaforce par exemple ici on dirige une
moto à réaction qui tirent des missiles
dont le but est visiblement de répandre
la démocratie en détruisant des villes
du moyen-orient et des soucoupes
volantes aussi voilà voilà
mais en même temps quand tu vois de quel
film est tiré le jeu fallait pas
s'attendre une oeuvre d'art
[Musique]
vive l'amérique
évidemment tant que je suis sur atari
2600 je suis obligé de vous parler de
itil extraterrestre le jeu le fameux jeu
qui a été définie comme étant le pire
jeu jamais existants ce jeu est-il
extraterrestres et célèbre d'ailleurs
parce qu'il a été une des grandes causes
du crash du jeu vidéo en 1983 en fait ce
jeu ah si peut marcher que atari a dû
faire enfouir des millions de cartouches
invendus dans le désert du nouveau
mexique
[Musique]
le jeu commence donc en haïti débarquent
sur terre dans son geste dans sa cabine
téléphonique
je précise que cet écran très moche
c'est une forêt et que ces trucs là ce
sont des trous retenez bien ça parce que
ce sont les deux seuls trucs que vous
verrez du jeu et donc nous y voilà le
jeu vous lâche ici sans instruction mais
évidemment ce n'est pas le manuel
donc d'après ce que j'ai compris le but
est de construire un téléphone pour
rentrer à la maison
alors le premier truc intéressant
security semble dotée d'un pouvoir de
téléportation instantané je me souviens
pas de ça dans le film est bon passons
d'ailleurs on peut aussi se téléporter
directement dans des trous c c'est très
con on se promène donc à travers les
différents écrans du jeu qui sont au
nombre incroyable de 4 en essayant
d'éviter l'agent du fbi y est le
scientifique qui s'il vous attrape vous
ramène dans ce qui semble être un temple
des douze maisons du zodiaque d'ailleurs
iti perd aussi de l'énergie en marchant
et quand le compteur arrive à zéro vous
mourrez mais heureusement à ce moment-là
elliott arrivée puis l'haïti mange
elliott visiblement savouré suscite
voila voila il faudrait vraiment que je
regarde le film de nouveau quand même et
notre pauvre iti évidemment n'a aucune
arme est la seule chose que fait le
bouton d'action c'est d'allonger son
coup
et pour une raison qui m'échappe ça
ralentit les ennemis mais enfin tu dire
l explication très simple
en cherchant les pièces du téléphone on
ramasse aussi ces points-là qui servent
probablement à quelque chose du jeune
c'est pour ça que ce jeu a eu des
mauvais retour au passé son temps à se
demander ce qu'il faut faire c'est quoi
ces icônes 1,9 point d'interrogation un
sourire un mec qui hurle mais à quoi ça
sert
est ce qui se met à insulter tout le
monde autour de lui quand il ya cette
icône activée mais bon tout ça c'est
qu'un détail à côté du principal défaut
de ce jeu et oui car si vous êtes un
jour par hasard amené à jouer à ce jeu
ce que vous allez vous demander surtout
ces bordels c'est quoi tout ce de
trou demeure de temps de jeu on passe
son temps à tomber dans des trous tout
le temps sans région à droite de l'écran
jetant dans un trou je vais à gauche
pendant un autre trou à temps et comment
je suis censé savoir qu'un trou ici je
sois changement d'écran est et ce qui
est fantastique c'est que quand tu
tombes dans un trou là mon cochon tu
peux accrocher pour monter pour ça il
faut appuyer sur actions puis sur os
pour que haïti s'envole et remonte à oui
parce que haïti vol en fait je voulais
pas dit
le souci c'est que quand tu es dans un
trou autant des fois tu remontera aux
lèvres autant des fois tu continues à
tomber en boucle simplement parce que tu
as pixels qui dépasse sans oublier
vraiment une couille dans le pâté avec
ce jeu j'ai deux pixels au dessus du
trou deux pauvres pixels mes pieds il
fabas bellouet des jetons km pignoufs va
te faire au tueur monture tom
thurman tueur tofu et le fun là dedans
et puis aussi c'est quoi ce concept
idiot en herbe 90% du jeu c'est sa
rentrée les sortir du trou non mais
citez moi une seule activité amusante
qui implique de rentrer et sortir d'un
trou comme ça pendant des heures e
la spéléologie oui la spéléologie oui ça
c'est oui c'est marrant
donc on s'amuse au début à tomber dans
tous les trous pour chercher des pièces
de téléphone parce que comme tout le
monde le sait le meilleur endroit pour
trouver des pièces de téléphone c'est
dans des troubles de la forêt jusqu'au
moment où on comprend que le coude qui
sert aussi à détecter les pièces de
téléphone
d'ailleurs je crois que ce qui me saoule
le plus dans la collecte des pièces
c'est sûrement quand le fixe se
téléporte sur toi comme un ninja pour te
piquer même elliott le gamin censé vous
aider en face à l'as car des fois il
vient vous racketter tous les points que
vous avez collecté qu'elles ont foiré
sérieux entre sa le flic qui a tout le
temps pour vous piquer votre téléphone
et le scientifique qui vous ramène pour
vous créneau dans le temple non mais
sérieusement mais il a atterri ou itil
adam 93 que tu m'étonnes qu'ils y
trouvent un téléphone pour partir chez
lui
[Musique]
alors très sincèrement il ya plein de
gens plein 6 qui disent que it is le
pire jeu du monde qui est d'accord je
suis je suis d'accord il a plein de
défauts il ya des incohérences il ya des
bugs mais il faut pas déconner c'est pas
le jeu du monde
je veux dire pour moi j'estime que tu te
fais largement plus intubé quand tu
achètes un jeu comme ça c'est tout ben
oui c'est fini ben fini très pas jeu
d'une manière flamboyante et irréaliste
quand tu fais d'habitude en europe bon
d'accord
[Musique]
mme été ramenée chez toi ici
oh merde j'avais dit qu'aujourd'hui
foutais rien et du nouvel an
un pays magique 3 tout le monde
[Musique]